i was
sitting in my office at university
college london
in
1986
when a force of nature appeared in my
office and that was fraser mustard
and fraser asked me about the whitehall
study
excuse me about the whitehall study and
i showed him
the social gradient in mortality and
fraser said this has profound policy
implications and i said fraser mrs
thatcher is prime minister
this is pure research it has no policy
implications whatever
fraser said you've got to come to canada
because it has policy implications in
canada
so he invited me the pop health group of
the canadian institute for
advanced research was just getting going
and he invited me to come to a meeting
so what do you want me to do he said
well it's rather informal
you've got an hour
start at 11
and go to 12 and then we break for lunch
and you're welcome to stay for the rest
of the meeting
so i started at 11
at i would say
90 seconds after 11 clyde hertzman asked
me a question
but when clyde asks you a question
that's not
like anybody else asking you a question
that's somehow penetrating to the core
of your being
at five o'clock in the afternoon i was
still talking
because i
get a bit further and clyde would be
i need to understand this clad i need to
understand what this is all about and
clyde michael wolfson bob evans
the people
in that network really
bored into it i'd never had an
experience like it in my life
and they said the social gradient we're
convinced that's what we've got to do
and then fraser said to me
have you thought about early child
development
and i said fraser i'm studying civil
servants
they sprung fully formed
with umbrellas and bowler hats
they had no childhood
well
clyde took the bit between his teeth and
as everybody has told you and you all
know he ran with it
so when it happened several years later
that i was asked to chair the who
commission on social determinants of
health
we convened nine knowledge networks we
said we wanted
the best people in the world to get
together in networks and we wanted
networks we wanted north-south
partnerships the best knowledge from all
over
and we convened nine knowledge networks
i decided what the areas were and the
first was early child development
and
i'd always wanted clyde to
work with me and for me
with him so i invited clyde to convene
the knowledge network on early child
development and i would say that
it's probably fair to say that i
bequeathed clyde the gradient
and he bequeathed me the importance of
early childhood
and i've become an advocate i'm a
not a passive consumer an active
consumer of other people's research on
early childhood
it's not the area that i personally have
been involved in researching but i've
been very much involved in taking the
knowledge that clyde with the knowledge
network on early child development
brought to us and i would say clyde's
fingerprints are all over the report of
the commission on social determinants of
health in a good way
and fraser was absolutely delighted that
our first substantive chapter in the
report was equity from the start
and that's fraser and that's clyde
so i'm so enormously grateful
for what i've got out of this
relationship
that's gone on since
this force of nature turned up in my
office in 1986 and said we've got to
explore the policy implications of your
research and i would say that's
what got me into doing what i'm doing
the report of the commission on social
determinants of health was published
in 2008
and we called that report closing the
gap in a generation
i heard a few moments just before the
break
that could be interpreted that people
were saying if things are difficult why
aren't we making more progress
my approach is completely different
which is
i don't
point to the
countries or the districts or the areas
where we're not making progress i point
to the ones where we are
and we are making progress and i'll show
you a few examples where countries have
taken on board what we said that we
could close the gap in a generation
i spent my life as a researcher but i
said we have the knowledge to close the
gap in a generation we have the means to
close the gap in a generation what we
now need is the will to close the gap in
a generation and in the light
of
the who commission which
was for all countries everywhere
i was asked in britain
how could we translate the findings of
your who commission into a form that
would be suitable for one country
england
in order to
address health inequalities
and i called my report fair society
healthy lives it was a bold claim
that if we put fairness at the heart of
all policy making health would improve
and health inequalities would diminish
one of the questions
that's reasonable to ask
is anybody listening
in england
three-quarters of local authorities have
marmot implementation
i met
a local councillor from manchester
and she said you're marmod i didn't
realize marmot was a person
we talk about implementing marmot that's
what we're doing up in manchester
so what's happening at the national
level is not altogether favorable in
terms of action on social determinants
and health inequalities but there's
action at local level and i'll show you
uh
a further example of that
and then i was invited by suzanne jacob
the director of the regional office for
europe at who
to conduct a review of the the european
review of social determinants of health
and the health divide and we published
that we launched it in london in october
last year
trying to get on the agenda of 53 member
states
that make up the who european region
i was trying to explain to americans
about the who european region that it's
the whole of the former soviet union i
said to them it goes so far to the east
you can practically touch sarah palin
and
i don't share your amusement at that
prospect
you'll recognize this it's my simplified
version of clyde's big model that he did
for
the knowledge network of the commission
we were invited to do a review of the
evidence by
one of the children's charities that was
providing services for children and we
said okay if you want to improve
outcomes for children
you've got to look at children's health
and development you've got to look at
parenting and you've got to look at the
context in which parenting takes place
parents lives so you can see
where my intellectual debts are
where we get those ideas from
this is
one way of why it matters this is from
our european review of social
determinants and the health divide
i have to explain e e is estonia s e is
sweden there is a rumor going around
europe that there's a swedish paradox
that as one researcher said sweden is
doing everything michael marmot
recommended and they still have huge
health inequalities well i look at these
data and say what swedish paradox
they've got
the longest life expectancy at age 25
of these countries and pretty narrow
inequalities by education and i
apologize for this i see
that's low education and higher
education
there's a second message
the variation in mortality in life
expectancy is much bigger
for
men with low education
if you've got high education you can
just about get away with living in
estonia or hungary or romania or
bulgaria
if you've got low education you can't
so there's
a difference of where you find yourself
that the consequences of having low
education matter much more in some
countries than in others
and that tells us
that we can potentially do something
about the social gradient it's shallower
in sweden
than it is
in estonia and hungary in romania we can
do something about it
why am i sharing this now well we're
talking about early child development
early child development as you've heard
all day
is absolutely key
in determining
educational levels
through the life course early child
development readiness for school what
happens through the school system
education
whether it's the education per se or as
clyde
talked about accumulation of advantage
and disadvantage through the life course
early child development education and
then what education predicts in terms of
income
and living conditions and so on
is an important question
our own analyses of these data suggest
education probably is important along
with other things
but it's showing you how important
education is right across europe and
there is the data for women
the differences are smaller the gradient
is shallow for women
i want to touch on three levels of
action which i could call macro miso and
micro
you saw a version of this from neil
halfon
this morning
this was the previous report card
from
looking at the oecd countries
and looking at country ranking
inequality and child well-being
the minister of health from
one country
said
in a who context when i was presenting
results from our european review
i don't think who should be involved in
social determinants health is a matter
of individual responsibility
it's not for who to get involved in
social things
and i said you can blame adults
perhaps for their lifestyle but don't
blame the children
they didn't choose to be born in poverty
they didn't choose their parents you're
going to blame in some biblical fashion
the sins of the parents will be visited
on the children unto the fourth
generation let's give our kids a fair go
and i'd say canada is gets a b minus
the united kingdom gets a c
and i do like lecturing in the united
states
can we do anything about this
here child poverty is defined as having
less than 60 percent median income
and we're looking at child poverty
before and after taxes and social
transfers
compare for example latvia and sweden
before taxes and transfers child poverty
in latvia is 35 percent in sweden is 32
after taxes and transfers
in latvia
it's still around 25
in sweden it's 12
in slovenia it's even lower
clearly
the swedes and the slovenians are
intolerant
of child poverty
they run their system to have lower
levels of child poverty that will have
an impact on everything we've been
talking about today
i was
speaking to the opening session of the
american public health association
meeting in the beginning of november 7
000 people in this vast
football stadium
i said how's the u.s doing
and i showed them the data the us looks
worse than latvia
and i said you have a democracy
this must be the level of child poverty
you want otherwise you'd vote a
government in that had a lower level of
child poverty harvey feinberg president
institute of medicine said to me do you
think you'll get asked back
and if we look what's happening in
britain
look at the blue curve
which is the uk
i've got northern ireland separately but
just look at the blue curve
the
dotted line is what would have happened
to child poverty
without
the fiscal changes that the current
government
has made
the solid blue line is child poverty
because of the fiscal changes the tax
and benefit reforms that the current
government has made
and i've shown this
to cross government department of
officials and i've said
clearly government policy is increasing
child
poverty
that will other things being equal have
an adverse impact on early child
development
and the government's response to that is
to put out a consultation to change the
measurement of child poverty
and i said that may
benefit politicians that will not
benefit one single child in the country
i probably won't get asked back there
either
and family policy generosity
makes a difference to child poverty this
is from our nordic knowledge network
usa australia island uk canada it's very
bad for you this is a political
statement in this country i know it's
very bad for you to be in an
english-speaking country because you
have high child poverty levels it's
clear
family policy generosity is greater in
sweden norway and finland and they have
lower levels of child poverty and the
way that might work is allowing two
parents to go out to work
and subsidize child care
preschool education we know is important
and
looking right across europe of the
countries where children are not getting
access to pre-school education it's a
soluble problem and it's not being sold
i think i may have got this from clyde
actually looking at
enrollment in preschool
in cuba and other latin american
countries
and reading levels in sixth grade
so it's looking at the percent of
children getting at the high level of
reading in sixth grade and cuba which
has the highest enrollment in preschool
has the best reading scores in latin
america
and the lower the enrollment
in preschool education the lower the
reading scores
in these different latin american
countries cuba's not the richest of the
latin american countries but it's got
the highest enrollment in preschool and
the best reading schools at that age
and we can see a difference in piece of
scores the program of international
student assessment by
whether or not children had a year or
more of preschool education so at age 15
there's better scores on maths literacy
and science if children were enrolled in
preschool
than if they weren't
after accounting for socio-economic
background
so profound effects and i showed you the
graph on educational mortality and i
said
this is a manifestation of this life
course effect of early child development
what happens
preschool what happens in schools
i have to show you this it's sort of
departing slightly because i get asked
commonly
other examples where people have reduced
the gradient
where they've made a difference
this is stunting by family income in
brazil
for different years of surveys so
1974 five at the top and 2006 7
stunting by family income
they have
closed the gap they've made the gradient
shallower they've really done it
it's possible i could show you under
five mortality in bangladesh
they've reduced the social gradient in
under five mortality in bangladesh
so it's not the case that inequalities
are always getting bigger
they are in some cases but we've got
important and inspiring examples
where the social gradient can get
shallower
miso level
sweden is interesting
i was giving a lecture in sweden
last year
and
a parliamentarian said
you know most reports get forgotten your
who commission report is still being
discussed in the swedish parliament five
years later
and you have to come to the parliament
so i went to the swedish parliament
and i said to them with respect
if you were not just discussing it but
doing something about it
and then i told them
i had the previous day addressed the
swedish association of local authorities
and regions 300 people representing
local authorities from all over sweden
who were all
developing plans to implement the who
commission on social determinants of
health in malmo they read the who
commission they said our national
government's not doing anything about it
we'll do it in the city of malmo and it
was set up by the deputy mayor not by
the health people
they asked me when they finished imam i
was sort of the
padronne of the malmo commission they
said what should we do now i said get on
the road and talk about it tell
everybody in sweden what you've done
and they have been
and their six areas for action were very
similar to our who and my english review
you saw this in neil slide uh slides
just an example of the social gradient
when somebody from mcmaster said this
morning what about
a living
wage and what i wanted to say was look
if you look by
quintiles of income
it's a gradient
yes we've got to deal with poverty yes
we've got to deal with the living wage
but we want everybody to have the level
of early child development
that's available to the best of
hence the whole idea and thank you
michelle for before the break for
talking about proportionate universalism
that's why we talked about
proportionate universalism we want
universalist policies we want everybody
to get up to the top level
but we may have to work harder the more
deprived
and again clyde was a great influence on
me the importance of monitoring
after we published the english review
on the one year anniversary in 2011 on
the two year anniversary and we'll do it
again this year on the four-year
anniversary we published a set of
indicators the marmot indicators and one
of which was the percent of children age
five achieving a good level of
development
by
level of affluence and deprivation of
local authorities and what you can see
is the more affluent the local authority
the better the level of early child
development
i presented this in the british
parliament some joker said i think the
proportion of variance explained would
be quite low in that correlation i
thought that's what mps most want to
discuss the multiple r squared
i said what the gentleman was trying to
say is this variance around the line
which suggests two strategies one is
reduce poverty and i've shown you
examples of how fiscal policy can make
that better or worse
but the second is to ask the question
why for a given level of affluence and
deprivation some are doing better than
others
and i was invited to birmingham the
english city of birmingham
they said they had six
marmot champions one for each of my six
domains of recommendations and they had
one on early childhood
and what they were doing
we heard a lot before about learning
from experience what they did was they
took off the shelf programs that had
been evaluated elsewhere
have proven effectiveness and they
applied them and what happened
birmingham is more deprived than the
english average so if you look in 2007
the level of early child development in
birmingham as predicted from the level
of deprivation was worse than the
english average
and look what happened in three years
look what happened in three years
they closed the gap
in three years
wow
it is rocket science
they took some evaluated programs and
they applied them
and they worked
it can make a difference
that's pretty good
why am i showing you this
my new friends are the firefighters
i went to
merseyside liverpool this is west
midlands where birmingham is
because west midlands wrote and said
they wanted to become partners with us
the fire and rescue service i went to
liverpool
and the firemen
adopted me captured me or something they
took me to a fire station
and they said
we're all macho white men
and we'd go off and fight a fire and
somebody would have died and we'd come
back and we'd say
ah what a tragedy
they really shouldn't have happened
somebody should have done something
about preventing that fire
and then they said
somebody should have done something
maybe we should have done something we
spent six percent of our time fighting
fires
yeah they play poker whatever they do
the rest of the time that why shouldn't
we do it so they went into people's
houses and talked about fitting smoke
alarms and while they were there people
would say smoke alarms i've got a leaky
roof
and these burly macho white men became
social workers they say you know you can
get a grant from the local authority to
fix your roof
we can help you do that
and then they said do you know who dies
in fires you know mentally ill
heavy smokers alcoholics
so we better get people not to smoke in
bed and then they said while we're up
why don't we try and get people not to
smoke
and then they gave older people
cards so they could get into the gym in
the fire station so older people could
come and exercise then they got the kids
and they teamed up with liverpool
football club
and they got the kids off the street
and got them playing football
and then they got them in they'd say to
the kids do you want to come in and play
in the fire engine
when you go to liverpool
they
say this area right here is the most
deprived in britain i went to 17 of
those they're supposed to be the most
deprived britain so they go to this
deprived area they get the kids in and
the kids say what are those things in
the ground and they say they're
vegetables
vegetables what do you do with them you
eat them really that's green things so
they got the kids
growing vegetables
and the
west midlands they've been taking kids
off on these adventure things it's great
so the year i spent as president of the
british medical association i said to
the gps do you know what the fire
fighters are doing to address social
determinants of health what are you
doing
so we produced a report on what health
professionals could do to address
social determinants education and
training working with individuals and
communities
the nhs as employer improving working
conditions of employees working in
partnership with others early child
development and being advocates
being advocates for better social policy
we got 19
health and medical organizations to give
us written commitments the royal college
of physicians the royal college of
psychiatrists of gps the obstetricians
the physiotherapists the midwives the
nurses all signed up
to what they do what they would do on
social determinants
and
macro
it's like clyde's expanding diagram
although i'm coming in what happens at
the family level really matters there's
the social gradient and socio-emotional
difficulties at age three
in the millennium cohort study we
classified parents
on their parenting activities
and various psychosocial inputs and what
you can see is you can statistically
explain about half the gradient in
social and emotional difficulties at age
three
and at age five by parenting activities
you can make a difference to the social
gradient and working outwards parenting
activities are as i said right at the
beginning influenced by the context in
which parenting takes place
thinking about our european review with
these 53 countries the whole of the
former soviet union countries are at a
very different level in terms of what
they
are doing and what they feel they can do
in terms of social policy so we said
if you're doing
nothing
do something
it makes a difference
it would make a difference in kyrgyzstan
in kazakhstan if you did something
if you're in poland or the czech
republic and you're doing something do
more
and we've given you the evidence on what
you can do and if you're in sweden do it
better
because as everyone has said today
we think
we have the knowledge to make a real
difference
and the reason we should be making this
difference is to create
societies
you